[音楽]
voodoo
[拍手]
皆さん海外旅行にはよく行きますか
旅は好きですか
飛行機から見下ろす初めての国知らない言葉の違い放送
外に出たときの意外な気温入国新車でパスポートを差し出す時のちょっとしたドキドキ
自分の荷物をレーンからとって今きっとを目的地があるはずです
私が今日皆さんにお話ししたいのはこの時時とは全く違う気持ちで外国に降り立つ人
たちのこと
私がこの2年半で行ってきた
難民と呼ばれるユジン龍野話すです
実は難民というのはその人が持つ
背景の1つでしかありません
それぞれの夢を持つ彼らはいつか平和や債券に向かう
次世代の祖国の見ないでなんです
情熱系の人もシャイな人も開かれみあもやきもち家さんも
そしてお父さんキャラの人もいます
それは私が友人という対等な立場で
かレイアウト関わって分かったことでした
紛争人権侵害迫害
それらの理由から自分の国をのが猿のがれざるを得ない人たちがいます
そのなかで日本にやってくる人たちもいます
今からお話しするのは彼らと一緒に私たちが始めた活動のことその前に一つ彼らの
ストーリーを見てみましょう
想像してみてくださいあなたの国は独裁政権で今日も反対を唱える人たちは拘束をされ
続けています
罪のない市民がたくさん殺されました
仲間が拘束されました脅迫文が送られてきました
身の危険がついにあなたまで迫ってきているということです
命をつなぐにはこの国を出るには
アメリカカナダドイツにビザを申請しました
難民になるためのビザなんて世界中どこにもないので一番早く取れそうな短期滞在の
ビザ
いわゆる観光ビザです
でも実際はビザがほとんどおりなかったり
取得するのに何カ月もかかることがほとんど
唯一ビザが取れたのはイチかバチかで申請した
ジャパンでした
japan か車パリ目くらいしか知らないしだいたい英語を話せるのかなぁ
小学校の時に習った広島と長崎のことしか知りません
でも経済もテクノロジーも発展している平和な国日本ならもしかしたらしばらくの間
命をつなぐとっかかりになるかもしれない唯一のチャンスでしたあなたは国を出ること
に決めました
ああああああ
そして降り立った成田空港あまりの寒さに身震いをしました
日本には国連の難民キャンプも制度の難民シェルターもありません
物価がわからず1泊1万円で泊まっていたホテル
手持ちのお金がなくなっていくスピードに驚きをもって安い
ゲストハウスに移動しました
ラン民支援の団体に教えてもらって難民認定申請をしました
結果まで3年くらいかかるという驚くべき事実をそこで知ります
3年もかかるのそれまでどうしたらいいんだろう
これが品川にある入国管理局
申請のための長い長い列に並びました
住むところもない友達もいないここから6か月は仕事をする許可さえありません
第2の人生が始まりました
しばらくして食べ物を提供してくれる団体や日本語を教えてくれるボランティアの教室
の存在を知りました
でもそれ以外は
何もやることがありません
寒さをしのぎに24時間行っている中なマクドナルドに入ったら wi-fi が
つながりました
あなたにとって
持ってきたスマートフォンだけが唯一
家族と連絡をする手段です
目に飛び込んでくるのは痛々しい写真やニュース
銃を持った軍前抗議する市民のでも折り重なったしたい
隣国に逃れる人たちの疲れた顔
この間まではあなたはその中で
平和を願う仲間たちと一緒に声を上げていました
でも今は遠く離れた安全な場所から
ただあ面を見つめています
これでいいのだろうか
僕は今ここで何をやっているんだろう
大事な友人たちが語ってくれる日本に来たばかりのころの物語です
難民というのはその人の背景の一つでしかありません
そしてその人がたまたま置かれた環境の一つでしかありません
ものすごい奇跡とすごく大きな努力
それが積み重なって日本に逃れてきた人たちがいます
彼らはこう言います爆弾は落ちてこないよ
でも今日も人間として生きた心地がしないんだ
そしてこうも言います僕はちょっともっと何かできるはずなんだ
ん
わたしもそう思います
だから私は難民の若者たちの仕事をつくる仕事をしています
静岡県富士市にある私の実家は npo でした
学校に行かない子供たちとか家庭に居場所がない若者たちの学校でもない家庭でもない
第3の居場所づくりをしています
普段は出会わない同世代や
弟妹世代の子たちと共に過ごしました
3日間会から避難するそう言ってきた女の子がその後6ヶ月住んでいたこともありまし
た
しかも私の部屋にです
朝自転車で二人乗り用して高校に行くこともありました
いま彼女はままになっていて私の一緒の大親友です
そんな子たちと話すのが私はとっても楽しかった
マイノリティ大多数ではないがはその中にあるユニークさを知りました
大学時代バングラデシュの先住民族の地域で2年間過ごしました
ここはミャンマーとの国境沿い見えない紛争地です
そこで現地の若者たちと奨学金の仕組みをつくったり犬子様で豚を育てて村の中でお金
と知識を
まーすプロジェクトに参加したり
国連開発計画の平和構築プロジェクトプログラムにおいて村の人が家からのアンケート
を求めたり
彼らの中から出てくる提案やアイデアを形にする
そんなことをしていました
気づいたら現地の文字のない先住民族語がペラペラになっていました
でもここは
[音楽]
村が焼かれても女の子が性的暴力に遭っても
戒厳令が出されても世界からずっと見えない
取り残された地域でした
声無き声が地球の表側に届く世界
そんな事を思い描き始めたのはこのころです
日本に帰ってきてずっと自分で解けなかったとい国家が守らない守れない国民はこの
地球でどうやって生きることができるんだろう
これを探すためのカギ人間の安全保障という考え方に出会って
大学院へ進みます
入学の時間が貼りやすに学生起業家が集うあるセミナーに参加しました
そこで提案した日本の地域が波を受け入れるアイディア
これの反応がすごく冷たかったのを覚えています
日本にテロが起きたらどうしてるの犯罪予備軍じゃないといえる
もしかしたらイメージからこんな気持ちが皆さんの中にも少しあるかもしれません
でも実際は違ったんです最初に話したとおり彼らはユニークで明るくて聡明で素敵な人
たちでした
彼らが用い夢は壮大で面白くて
そしてワクワクします女の子たちが教育を受けられるような社会にしたい
母国の貧しい学生たちが安心して学校に行けるような奨学金をつくってみたい
コーヒーの産業を通して日本と自分の村をつないでいきたい
日本で前に進もうとしている人たちがいます
でも
彼らの前には大きな大きな壁がありました
難民として認定されるまでひたすらそれを待ち続けるという日々は社会的にも経済的に
も法的にもとてもとても不安定です
5難民認定されるかわからない5就労許可が剥奪されるかもわからない
不安定なビザではちゃんとした仕事に就くことも難しい方
いって国に帰ることはできない
日本で去年難民認定された人数は何だと思いますか
ジャン麺ながら
20人でした
ちなみに日本で去年難民認定申請をした人の数は
196208人でした
まみん認定率は g 7諸国でぶっちぎりの最下位です
でも一方で日本は海外の難民船や国際協力には多額の支援をしています
でも日本では残念ながら
難民認定はほとんどおりません
命をつないできた日本で次の一歩を踏み出すことの難しい状態にいる人たち
失望怒り
諦め悲しみそして鉄棒
この難しい状況の中もしあなただったらどうしますか
もしかしたら誰かを責めたくなるかもしれません
でもきっとそうじゃない方法もあるはず
だから
批判ではなく対案を
社会の側からあっと驚くような良い方法を作り出していつか
政府に真似してもらえるぐらいのものを作ろう
それがあたしたちが難民の人たちと始めた活動でした
ノッツ灯カバー飛ぶイージートークイージー
ラミ問題について話すんじゃなくて
難民と話そうこれが原点でした
怖いとかハワイそうというイメージ
新聞やテレビや本からイラクイメージ
けど
実際にその人たちと話してみたらどうでしょう
悠然としてハマス彼らはいろんな世界を見せてくれます
大好きなスポーツの話こきょうの料理の話
広がる夢の話ある日突然家の前が爆破された日の話
私たちには知り得ない世界を教えてくれる存在でもあります
今こんな空間が広がりつつあります3つあるんですけど
主な事業というか大事だと思っていること
東空一とリーグいると work with
から
難民について話すんじゃなくてコナミの人たちと話そうとか始まった
lg サロンで本当にいま何が起こっているのかということを彼らから並ぶっていう
バーを
毎週毎月設け続けています
talk with ともに話す
lg サロンは難民の人たちと日本の人たちが交流したいはする場所です
2年前波問題に興味がある人にどこに行ったら出会えるのかそもそも
難民の人たちにどうやって出会えるのか分からなかった時
ラン民当事者でもある友人と初めて見たのがこれでした
それから月に1回開催をしていますがここは支援の場所ではありません
多様な友人に出会う場ですこれまで中学生からシニア層まで1000人以上
26か国以上の人が参加をしてきました
以上に残ってるエピソードを一つ
大学で難民問題を勉強する女子大生が初めてこのサロンに参加した後私にこう言いまし
た
さやかさん難民て笑うんですね
ここにいるみなさんならもうわかってくださっているかもしれません
波に乗って笑うしなく c ジョークも言うし
拗ねる c 怒る時だってあります人です当たり前のことです
その女の子は今スタッフとしてこの大はラバーを作り出す重心に入ってくれています
リブリずともに暮らす
ここは私たちがたくさんの支援者さんと一緒に購入したシェアハウスの縁側です
一時避難の場所だけではなく長期的なクラスと働くにつながるような
ただいまと言えるようなハウスに
ここに日本のハウスマネジャーとアフリカから来たハウスマネジャーがご近所散歩の
草刈りの時間を共有したり
ゴミ出しの時の挨拶を交わしながら一緒に少しずつ交流の輪を広げています
このコンセプトを作りたいというところから始まり
一級建築士不動産屋さん会社員
難民島時差ご近所さん
外国人とかに日本人とかいう黒垣根を越えて
毎週末の diy を経てこの場所がついに夏にオープンしました
実は私もこのようなシェアハウスに暮らしていますがとっても賑やかです
ゴスてリアーレゲエの賛美歌が阿蘇起きると聞こえてくる子もあったりします
さて work with
共に働く
レアの中にある意欲経験能力を発掘し職業や企業につなげていくという試みです去年
二人のプログラマーと今年一人のエンジニアが自分の大好きを活かして働き始めました
西アジア出身のそのプログラマーは社長さん等とても相性がよくって
余暇の時間や仕事の時間に一緒に過ごしている写真が
ために届きます
彼はすぐに
その後アプリケーションを作ってしまって裏にある不思議な行動を私に見せてくれたん
ですが私はプログラミングがさっぱりなので
1すごいねといったものを実は何も分かってなかったのは彼にはナイショです
このように難民として働くではなくて自分として働く場を作っています
人を
ラン民としてくるのは日本人としてくるぐらい
いやもしかしたら人間としてくるぐらい雑なことなのかもしれません
波の中には20代もいれば50代もいれば女性もいる c 断線もいるし
プログラマーも牧師さんも料理人も人権活動家までいますだから難民という言葉自体を
覆したい
逆境を乗り越えてきた彼らは
抜群の人間力と創造力と優しさを兼ね備えています
難民
実はそれは社会課題ではなくて社会の課題を解決に導く
チェンジメーカーたちでした
私たちはそもそも支援しますというスタンスではないので
愛は息をアイディア君たちめっちゃいいアイディアだねそれ
そう言ってこちらに来てくれる人たちもいます
何かが合致した時それが一緒に前に進みます
私の仕事は彼らの夢の後押しをすること
民主主義が自分の国に戻ってくること
児童労働のない産業構造に変えること
若者が自分の意見を言えるような社会になること
国を超えた経済圏を作り出すことでこれまで届かなかった場所にサービスが届くように
なること
私一人では叶えられないたくさんの夢を担っているのが彼らなんです
難民という背景を超えて一人の人間として思いっきり自分を表現できる
思いっきり自分を生きられるそんな社会に
ゲイたあげようではなくて共に生きようという姿勢は彼らの希望の光を灯し
あなたの可能性をも広げてくれるかもしれません
こんなカラフルな彼らに会いに行きませんか
人を信じ人が持つ可能性を信じられるように
人の可能性を潰すのも人なら灯すのも人です私はその希望を灯し続けたい
[拍手]
[音楽]